Instructor: There are
a number of upgrades to object
literals in ES6 and these are
some that I use absolutely every
single day. These are probably
some of the more practical
things of ES6 that you're going
to be using. This is an
example where I've got all these
variables -- first, last age,
and breed -- and I need to put
them into an object so I would
say const dog = make myself an
object and I go, "Hmm, I need
first, I need last, I need age,
I need breed." Pop those
suckers in there, but the
property names are the same as
the variables, so I'm just going
to take the property name and
paste the variable in there.
That is OK, but it's very
repetitive because we're doing
the same thing over and over
again. I've just made that
object with all those variables
inside of it. If we console.log
that, you'll see it's just a
regular object here. No
problem, but what you can do is
if the property name and the
variable you're setting it to
are named the exact same thing,
you do not need to do this twice.
That's actually why I'm getting
these red lines here. My ESLint
is telling me, "Hey, it's
unnecessary." What you can do is
just take them out. This may
look a little bit weird, because
right now this kind of looks
like an array, but it's really
an object. Doing that it still
gives us the exact same object
that we're looking for, just
without the repetitive property
name is equal to the actual
variable name. You don't have
to go all in on that. That's
only when that is the actual
case. For example, if you want
to rename it to firstName and it
would be first, that's no
problem there. Similarly, if you
want to add just pals, it would
be Hugo and Sunny. Then
that is just a regular array.
You only need to use it when the
property name and the variable
name are exactly the same.
That's pretty straightforward.
You can start using that,
absolutely, already. Another
update is when you have method
definitions inside of an object.
Let's say we have a modal object
here, so let's say const modal =,
and inside of that we have three
methods. We've got create, we've
got open, and we have close. All
three of those are functions in
which, they are just a function,
and after each one we have a
comma here. We did that on,
and on, and on. However, what
you can do instead of doing that
is just leave out the word
function and leave out the colon,
and that is the exact same thing,
so create () is the exact same
thing as doing colon function,
it's just a shorthand.
There's no weirdness with the
keyword this or anything, and
that's exactly why I said you
should not use an arrow function
when you're using a method of an
object, because we have this
other shorthand here and it's
not going to monkey with the
scoping of any of your variables
or the keyword this. We can just
take that to there and that to
there. Similarly, if you had
any params that you needed to
pass it, like maybe a selector
here, maybe some content here,
maybe like a goodbye message
here, you can just pass them in
as you normally would into a
function. Those are two big
updates to the object literal.
A third one I want to talk about
is something called computed
property names. It's also
something that you might not use
every single day. Good to know
in case you'll ever run into a
situation when you need it.
Let's set up a little example
where we have a key that needs
to be set on an object. We'll
make a key variable and we'll
say pocket color. Why? Because
we're going to make a tshirt
here and the tshirt has a whole
bunch of different attributes
about it, like pocket color,
main color, ink color, sleeve
color, all these things.
We're going to talk about the
pocket color here, and we have a
value of that actual color is
going to be set to yellow. We
need to use these variables to
set a property and a value of an
object. What we could do is
say const tshirt = object
literal. Previously what we've
been able to do is you can say
key is equal to the actual value.
Let's take a look at what we've
got so far. Console.log tshirt,
there's the tshirt. The
pocket color has been
dynamically set, and if I were
to change this from pocket color
to ink color, see the variables
are now updated to ink color. We
are creating an object literal
with it. That has always been
possible, but one thing that is
now possible is, what if we
wanted the opposite color to go
along with that as well, because
maybe we are printing something
on top of that pocket and we
needed to know what is the exact
opposite color of that? It could
go on top of it. I've got a
little function right here that
I'm going to bring in. It's just
a function that takes in the hex
code and returns the inverse
color, so just the opposite
color. If I wanted to make a
key of pocket color opposite,
how would I do that? I could
make another variable here and
then say opposite, but
that's not really what I'm
looking for. What we need to
do is we need to compute the
copy. What we can do here is
just use a function, a template
string or any other JavaScript
right inside of the property
name. I'm going to give myself
the key and then tack on the
word opposite. We can use this
function that I run here, invert
color, and it's going to take
the value as well. Look at
what's going to happen. We
refresh, key has already been
declared,
because I made two
keys here. We've got pocket
color and pocket color opposite.
Those are being dynamically set
on this actual variable.
Previously what you had to do,
is you would have had to make
the tshirt object, then go and
update the tshirt object like
that and like that.
Which is not the end of the
world, but it's kind of cool
that we can now do it inside of
our object literal. As we define
it, we can compute the property
keys. Let's look at one more
example here, where sometimes
you have some funky data that
you get in from an API and you
don't have too much of an option
to work with. Obviously, you
would have a little bit of a
nicer structure but sometimes
you might have a keys array,
which is size, color, and
weight. Then you have a values
array, which is something like
medium, red, and 100, and you
need to make an object where the
size is medium, the color is red
and the weight is 100. You
could make an object here where
you say const shirt =, you could
say keys of zero, and that's
actually a computed property
name here. One cool thing that
you could do is you say keys.
shift = values.shift and then do
it once more, and again.
That's the same code three times,
but what is it going to do? Size
medium, color red, and weight
100. What happens here is that
essentially we just plucked off
one from each of the arrays as
we went through. You can just
run the same code over and over
again. Obviously, you could
have also just looped over them
and set it on the shirt after
the fact, but that's another
example to show you when you
might be able to use computed
property keys.